Gazi Anwar AJ Domo is a cancer survivor
who regulated travels abroad for
treatment annex appointment is in India
in May but because of the global
pandemic
she says the local hospitals don't and
even if you decide to calling an
emergency so whether you have a concern
is echoed by many in the country
illnesses of Nadia's regularly seek
medical attention in other countries
every year because of the poor state of
the public health care system here the
travel restrictions imposed by countries
around the world has now forced many
including the rich and the powerful to
stay home and rely on the same health
system they neglected for decades
using these hospice ready public
hospitals initially now you have an
added on effect of more persons now
having to utilize resources for obvious
reasons because a kind of a trap the
increase in the number of people using
local hospitals is adding stress to a
system that's already in a bad state
many here hope the pandemic will force
public officials to focus on improving
Nigeria's health care system an
estimated 1 billion dollars is spent by
Nigerians on overseas medical treatment
every year including government of
issues in 2017 Nigeria's president spent
about 20 weeks in hospitals in the
United Kingdom although government
promised to address the problems
in the health system here nothing much
has improved some Nigerians say they
will avoid local hospitals for now not
because they have alternatives but
because they fear doing so will put them
at a greater risk for coffee 19 Hamid
Idris al Jazeera Abuja